because there are thousands of these
families and joining us now tonight
are nine brave americans whose loved
ones
were killed by illegal immigrants the
ones you're saying manufactured crisis
including wendy and dj corcoran their
son pierce
22 years old was just killed this past
december 29th by a suspected illegal
immigrant in knoxville
he was driving on the wrong side of the
road wrong side of the highway
22 years old we're also joined by laura
wilkerson her son joshua
was beaten and strangled and set a fl
flame on fire by a classmate who was in
this country
illegally joshua was 18 years old
then we have steve ronabeck his son
grant is raising money for college
he worked overnight in a convenience
store shot by an illegal immigrant
robbing the store where grant was
working overnight
the midnight shift agnes gibbons also
with us her son
ronald de silva was shot in a driveway
by an illegal immigrant gang member
who had previously been deported and
let's introduce michelle root
her daughter sarah was killed by an
illegal immigrant
who was drunk driving and he disappeared
after posting bail
why did he get bail we're also joined by
marianne mendoza
her son police sergeant brand brandon
mendoza was killed by
a drunk driver in the country illegally
and immigrant
in a head-on collision also with us
maureen maloney her son
matthew denise was literally killed by
any illegal alien who was drunk driving
and lastly
we introduced sabine durden her son
dominic was killed in a collision
by an illegal immigrant who had two
prior dui
convictions and dominic was a 9-1-1
dispatcher
maureen and sabine are angel moms who
serve as directors for
advocates for victims of illegal
immigrant alien crime and they all join
us
thank you all for coming anything worse
just a general question i i'm a parent i
have two kids
i don't think there's anything worse
than losing your son or daughter
right it's it's not it's not natural we
don't bury our kids right
and i've met many mothers and fathers of
servicemen and women they go through
this
but they know they're going into a risk
when you find out
that it's somebody that was already in
the criminal justice system
and they're here illegally in your case
you're like the newest member of this
club that nobody wants to be a part of
and you just lost your son right wendy
on the 29th right 29th of december um
first how you guys holding up this is
still new to you
i think we're still numb still in shock
about it
and to a degree and then finding out so
many
people are hurting over the same thing
i mean we're it's just painful yeah it
is very cool every day you wake up when
it's there
the reality hits every morning that it
is
that's the hardest time in the morning
when you wake up when you wake up you
feel like you're
you're going to wake up from from a bad
dream and then
the tears come and you realize it's real
14
years the driver in this case was in the
country
had every opportunity to do the right
thing and come here
legally and become a productive citizen
but he chose not to
and what about his past criminal record
they
don't they won't reveal it well they're
they're saying that there is no criminal
record that's how he was able to stay
here for this long because
there was there was nothing yeah that
they know of
that they know of laura i've known you
now you've done a lot of interviews with
me over the years
uh good to see you good to see you um
your son was only 18 years old
yes brutally beaten murdered set of
ablaze yes tell us that story
uh it absolutely is a nightmare you know
sent josh to school one day and he just
never came home and i started looking
around for him
and i finally found his truck parked
next to a dumpster and
called police and they came and called
me over and everything that was his
shoes and stuff were in that dumpster
and we waited in that parking lot all
evening and
finally they arrested a suspect he came
back to the crime scene
and they arrested him there and when
they took him down to
the jail he um had joshua's truck in his
pocket
and finally about 24 hours later he told
us where we could find josh
and um and they've been set a fire after
being brutally beaten yep
he bound him up with 13 ropes around his
neck into
the back of his hands behind his back
and through a belt loop
and then to his feet tied him up like so
he could carry him
and then he put him in joshua's truck
and then drove around and bought
how long ago was this for you 2010. it
doesn't get easier does it no
no you wake up just like the corcoran's
i feel for them because it's not you
know they know the story but i i just
know that they don't it's not their
story yet and
and that comes in time and then then the
really pain begins when
when the shock wears off and you realize
that you know that's forever i mean you
know
every christmas every thanksgiving every
birthday everybody
when you first go home you know there
are his books and there are socks on the
floor and
and it takes a long time to really get
your
heart and head in the same place to know
that they're not coming back
you know steve um i've known you now
also a couple of years
and i've interviewed you a number of
times amazing kid you had
your son was 21 years old grant he's
working in a convenience store doing the
graveyard shift midnight to eight shift
and
in comes a guy and your story his story
gets very interesting so
he was robbing the store right well he
wasn't actually robbing the store he
came in to buy a pack of cigarettes and
uh
dumped a jar of change out on the
counter grant went to start counting the
change
and wasn't counting it fast enough so
the man said what you're not going to
give me my cigarettes and grant said hey
i got to count the change
and the man produced a gun grant did
everything he was supposed to do he went
ahead and gave him the cigarettes
as soon as the man had the cigarettes he
went ahead and
executed grant shot him point blank in
the face
and that's when he robbed the store he
came around the counter grabbed two more
packs of stuff
on video yeah i don't know what that
would be like watching that video
i'm sure horrific for you um it gets
worse though
because this same illegal immigrant
had held a young woman hostage
brutally raped her had been in the
criminal justice system
how did he ever get out and how did he
not get deported he was uh
he was able to plead down his crimes to
felony burglary
and just get probation he kidnapped and
raped a woman for 10 days
repeatedly they filled her full of
heroin so they said
you know they said oh she's a drug
addict so she wasn't a reliable witness
and no she was drugged um
it makes it more painful knowing that
they had them
knowing that if they did their this is a
big part of this thing here
there are too many instances where the
government we have them
we identify them we put them in jail and
we'll talk about sanctuary cities and
states
then they won't hand them over to isil
they aid in to bet them in their next
crime
and and to me they've got some of these
guys have blood on their hands
by not following the law um it's so hard
to hear these stories because
all the promise your kids are so young
uh
22 21 18.
and i'm looking at your son agnes gibney
here her sons ronald
this picture by the way i can just walk
over without getting in the shot
that's tim at his wake
this is ronald in the coffin
this is the reality that i live with and
unlike
uh this is not manufactured i want to
tell the democrats this is not
manufactured
and i want to call on our president to
please
implement e-verify please stop the
incentive for illegal aliens to come to
our country and punish
employers this guy that murdered my son
who will be coming out of prison
next year my peace and quiet to be
taken away from me and my family because
i don't know if he's going to come after
me
why should he he's getting released he's
getting released but california being
a sanctuary state this happened in 2002
when you kill an innocent young man
why do you ever get out of jail exactly
he's going to get to enjoy his family
his children
and one other point that i wanted to
make when nancy pelosi said one time
that
her child her grandchild was having a
birthday
and he said he just his birthday wish
was he just wanted to have brown skin
well my grandchildren ronald's children
would also
uh like to make a wish to have their dad
back i do
i mean i look at that picture he's a
young man i mean look at him
i miss that smile i miss his beer hugs i
miss
everything about him my life changed
completely uh because of this and
what's even more offensive is that i'm a
legal immigrant we came to
follow the law we came to the right
channels to this country
why isn't my country and these
politicians standing up for me
and for the american citizens of this
country you know they stand up with
illegal aliens and criminals
you're all the faces i want america take
a look pam back and
these are the faces of a manufactured
crisis that's what the media says about
all of you and all of your experiences
manufactured these are real lives now
look at your beautiful daughter you have
a picture uh and
her and this is michelle root your
daughter's name is sarah correct
how old was she she was 21 when she was
killed
she had just graduated from college with
a 4.0
bachelors and criminal investigations
she was hit and killed that night
after celebrating on our way home edwin
mejia who came over unaccompanied at age
16
was driving not even his vehicle
street racing going 70 plus miles an
hour
uh blood alcohol 0.241
when he rear-ended my daughter's suv
legal limits 0.08
and he's at two 2.4 one
wow and they like to say it was three
times the legal limit no he's nineteen
he should have never had any alcohol in
him
and when did this happen to you it was
2016.
january 31st is what we consider her
death date
because she was brain dead when they got
her to the emergency room
however being the lovely that is a child
all american young beautiful 4.0 student
her whole life and career ahead of her
correct and she was an organ donor
and we saved six additional people that
night with her organs
but edwin mejia
made bond because the judge had set a
low bond
and he fled so he's out so sorry to all
of you i am so sorry
this has got to stop yes that's what the
show is about
i want people to see what this
manufactured crisis is not manufactured
she had a right to live your son had a
right to live your son had a right to
live
your children had a right to live you
know i i have known you now marianne
mendoza for a long time
look at he is really handsome thank he
looks like you
got his good looks he was a police
officer
he was he wanted to be a police officer
since he was very very young
and on may 11 2014 he had spent mother's
day with me
and went into work and was going to come
back for dessert he'd come for dinner
and
he said mom you know got too busy can't
come in so in the early hours of 2000
may 12 2014 he was on his way home from
work
and an illegal alien repeat criminal had
gone over 35 miles the wrong way on four
different freeways
three-time legal limit drunk high on
meth and his family let him
drive repeatedly leave a house and keep
going back and forth
and he slammed head on into my son and i
got a call at
quarter three in the morning from
afghanistan from a fellow mesa officer
who was also air national guard telling
me mom
he's been in a terrible accident and i
kept trying to call his phone and he
wasn't answering and then my worst
nightmare the doorbell ring and it was
mesa police
uh to come and take me to the hospital
and brandon you ran and died
i'm just i'm tr i've tried to put myself
in your shoes i think parents can do
that
i don't this is the one thing i don't
think you recover from oh and i don't
care how strong you think you
are you're not going to recover from
this and this is not a manufactured
crisis
this is where i have to go for his
birthday this is where i have to go for
christmas for every holiday
and just as recent as and michelle was
at my house in phoenix
i got three people contacting me four
and a half years later
talking about the things that my son had
done for them this has been a continual
for four and a half years so this wasn't
just a loss to me sean
is this a loss to my whole the media
asked you for interviews many in the
media
i know i've interviewed you many times
and a number of you you've been on
many times you don't fit your narrative
right you don't you don't get it
they don't want to hear the story and
then they they arrogantly go on to
you know how i feel about yeah one more
picture yes ma'am
this is 330 miles of our southern border
in arizona
330 miles and if the liberal
politicians think this is going to keep
criminals out of our country they're
insane
insane insane insensitive
cruel callous and in a sense
sanctuary cities and states from that
moment forward that they release people
and don't deport them and follow the law
they're aiding and abetting the next
crime
in my opinion i agree